here we go here's the here's the big
story from wcco cbs minnesota derrick
chauvin's attorney files motion for
new trial they report attorney eric
nelson has filed a motion for a new
trial for former minneapolis minneapolis
police officer derek chovin
in the death of george floyd nelson
filed the motion on the grounds of juror
misconduct
and that the court abused its discretion
for failing to agree to the defense's
request for a change of venue
and sequestering the jury i'ma stop
right there it's actually substantially
more comprehensive than that
this kind of feels like local outlets
are trying to downplay the defense as
they keep
doing it's particularly annoying see the
filing comes in the midst of a
controversy surrounding a photo
of juror brandon mitchell at the march
on washington last august last august
which included speeches from george
floyd's family members
he is seen wearing a t-shirt that says
get your knee off our necks
in his juror questionnaire mitchell
wrote that he had not attended any
protest over police brutality
mitchell told wcco monday that he was at
the march in support of ramping up voter
turnout that doesn't matter
they didn't ask did you go to a police
brutality protest
for another reason they said did you he
said no he lied
here's what gets crazy this dude is
interviewed in a podcast called like get
up erica i think it is get up mornings
with eric or something
where he's asked about jury dude he says
if you want to affect change i'm
paraphrasing you got to get on these
juries to affect change
i mean right then and right right there
you see his motivation
he wanted to get on the jury he lied to
get on the jury because he wanted a
guilty verdict that is not
impartiality but let me pull up the
actual file and then we'll start
we'll get into this check this out so
this is the actual legal filing
notice of emotion and motion they say
to the above named court the honorable
peter a cahill
judge of hennepin county district court
and matthew g frank assistant minnesota
attorney general
maybe the attorney general will take
this and go gee these are great
arguments i'm going to have a new trial
for chauvin
but i really doubt the judge cahill
receiving this is going to do anything
other than
no ignore it so this is this is the
defendant's notice of motions and
post-verdict motions they say
they're they're filing a motion for an
order granting a new trial
saying on the following grounds the
interest of justice abuse of discretion
the depr the deprived i'm sorry
abuse of discretion that deprived the
defendant of a fair trial
prosecutorial and jury misconduct errors
of law at trial
and a verdict that is contrary to law
the specific basis for this motion
include but not
but are not limited to they they say
they didn't change the venue
they abused its discretion when denied
the motion for a new trial on the
grounds of publicity during the
proceedings
threatened the fairness of the trial say
the court
failed to sequester the jury the state
committed pervasive
prejudice prosecutorial misconduct which
deprived chauvin of his constitutional
rights to due process in a fair trial
including
but not limited to disparaging the
defense improper vouching
and failing to adequately prepare its
witnesses the court
abused its discretion and violated
children's rights under the
confrontation clause
when it failed to order maurice hall to
testify
or in the alternative to admit into
evidence mr hall statements to law
enforcement regarding his interactions
with floyd
moyester hall was according to floyd's
girlfriend their drug dealer who was
there with george floyd
he played the fit he pleaded the fifth
and there were questions from the
defense as to why
the prosecution would not grant him
immunity and
order subpoena him to testify maybe
some people assume it's because they
want to charge this man later with
murder with the murder of george floyd
or at least have that open as an option
but they could have said you'll be
immune from prosecution now testify as
to what happened they didn't do it
we got more the court abused its
discretion when it submitted
instructions to the jury that failed to
accurately reflect the law
with respect to second-degree
unintentional murder third degree murder
and authorized use of force they say it
violated
mr chopin's rights when it permitted the
state to present
cumulative evidence with respect to use
of force that's interesting i guess
they're saying
there should have been one expert saying
here's what the policy is and be done
with it but they brought in multiple
people saying just different things
the court abused its discretion in
violation of chauvin's rights
when it ordered the state to lead a
witness on direct examination
they say they also failed so here's i
think this i
uh in the in the uh in the motion it
failed to order
that a record be made of the numerous
sidebars that occurred during trial
and they say jay the cumulative effect
of multiple errors and these proceedings
deprived mr shove in a fair trial
in violation of his constitutional
rights and then it finally gets to
two because it was one a b c d you know
you get it two it says an order for a
hearing to impeach
the verdict pursuant to minnesota r crim
p 26.03
subdivision 206 and schwartz v
minneapolis suburban busco
on the grounds the jury commit
misconduct felt
threatened or intimidated felt
race-based pressure during proceedings
and or failed to adhere to instructions
during deliberations in violation of
chauvin's constitutional right to due
process
and a fair trial they say a motion for
an order granting the defense additional
time to thoroughly brief the above
issues
and any other relief deemed fair and
equitable equitable by the court
the motion is based upon the files and
records in the case yeah you get the
point and i
really really doubt this will go
anywhere but
okay now that we've gotten through all
that the trial wasn't fair
in my opinion i don't know what uh what
you guys think and i don't think there's
gonna be a new trial but
if there is i don't know how many
buildings you think they'll burn down
this time
oh gosh that's the problem that's the
problem
seven that's a great number um a good a
good solid number seven can't go wrong
something's gonna be more than that
it'll be at least seven
yeah so they can't put this appeal until
after sentencing right
isn't that how this works this is a
motion for a new trial okay yeah i'm i'm
not sure i worse i'm not a lawyer
i don't think this is an appeal i think
they're outright saying
the court is out of order you all need
to give us a new trial
i really doubt i doubt they're going to
do that the judge was all
the judge already refused to do all of
these things listed
right like we're gonna have a trial
right here in the city while the city's
on fire
i'm sure that jurors will be fine about
that dude yeah the guy had a black lives
matter shirt on
at a protest the juror who says
to effect change you've got to weasel
your way you didn't say weasel get
get against these jerseys you don't get
on that journey to effect change you get
on a jury to be a neutral
arbor i i actually agree with what he
said
it's not about like for activism
purposes you know maybe i i just
i disagree with the spirit of what he
said but the idea is if you want to be
if you want positive change in your
community you've got to be active in
civics
you got to get on juries and when
someone's accused of like
i'll tell you this if i was on a jury
and this is what this will disqualify me
from all future juries related to gun
you know gun laws if i was on a jury and
they were like this young man
you know chicago inner city young black
man has a handgun and they're like he's
being charged with felony possession i'd
be like i've
i vote to nullify during nullification
that means you can as a juror choose to
say he's not guilty even if they
instruct you
like they give you instructions where
they say if the law says you can't have
a gun
and you believe he had a gun then he's
guilty you can go nah
i don't think it should be illegal to
have a gun so if it were me on a jury
i'd be like
nullify you you got to have a pretty
damn good case
to to get beyond reasonable doubt what
do they do in those cases if you're like
the lone juror
that mistrial so how long will they will
they deliberate until they're like we
can't it's a mistrial
i mean i don't know not a lawyer i'd
imagine it could be theoretically quick
if you were just sitting there with your
feet up you're like i will never change
my mind
like and i just plug your earrings and
go they might come out and be like he's
not going to budge we're not unanimous
there's no you know not unanimous so i
wonder if they could charge
this juror separately dude
i think he should get uh i think he
should get perjury yeah or something
they should they should but i don't i
mean that wouldn't affect sheldon in any
way so
no i mean if they did it would it would
probably force a new trial
but they're not going to do it because
the the judicial system is look man the
the the crazy terrorists got their way
they went around smashing up buildings
setting fires breaking windows and
you know uh cowardly cahill that's what
i call him he's the judge
just gave in and didn't didn't treat
this appropriately he could
he could have just said look we can't do
the trial here any reasonable person
would suggest as much
and he said no he kept the trial in a
place that's just absolutely ridiculous
and then he made those comments about
maxine waters remember he said
oh this could end up right and then he
keeps going forward
and you're just like dude what he was i
i my opinion he was scared
that if he said okay we're gonna move
venue he'd get the pig's head at his
house
yeah you hear about the juror the
witness who got a pigs out of this house
i heard the metaphor i know that
actually happened during the chauvin
case yes one of the witnesses for the
defense
his old house had a pig's head and blood
smeared on it this is like mafia tactics
dude it's it's terrorism and guess what
it worked
these people got what they wanted yeah
honestly
a new trial if you truly believe he's
guilty you i can't imagine you would
have a problem with another trial
you know what man we've already heard
from these leftists who are saying
why do we even need a trial we watched
it on video it's like dude because you
have no idea
like man man imagine how stupid that
statement is
because we've heard it from many
leftists saying we all sat on video
imagine i walk up to you ian
and i punch you in the face as hard as i
can right
and then you defend yourself
but when the police arrive they say you
hitting me and you get arrested for it
it's like old school bully tactics
yep so you can't just look at a video
and say
that like that's a definitive proof of
something
well point in case remember the capitol
hill insurrection
with brian sicknick remember it came out
that he was hit with the fire
extinguisher and not killed him
and then it came out later it was
national car like natural causes
right and so everyone said we saw the
video he got hit in the head and then
people were like that's how he died
and then they came back and said no he
had two strokes
you know when i started doing all the
live streaming stuff i had
journalists telling me like now that now
that we have this like live on the
ground reporting you can't fake news
anymore and i was like what do you mean
it's easier than ever to fake news
live streaming has made it easier to
fake news because people
believe they're watching raw real
footage it's so easy
to just it like lying is always easy and
and abusing people's trust is always
easy it's it's scary it's unfortunate
and we can see how the corporate press
takes advantage of that so you can't
just look at a video
and and most of us did i think almost
all of us did we watched the video and
we were angry about it
and then all sudden more information
came out and i think a lot of us got
embarrassed that we jumped the gun on
that one
i thought shoving was so guilty and
villainous and then i saw the second
video
of of uh what's his name why can't i not
remember this guy's name sometimes yeah
george floyd
just like kicking and whining about how
he can't breathe before he
even like in the car yeah like pushing
himself out of the cop car
and then he's on drugs i'm like what and
he's on fentanyl and meth and like
oh my god and but that that first video
was burned in my it was still burning my
brain i was just able to kind of
compartmentalize it
and i don't know if many people can do
that yeah
yeah well i thought it was weird the
defense attorney kept saying
like in his closing statement he said
any reasonable cop would have done this
any reasonable cut would have done not
and i said well i don't know if any
reasonable cop would have knelt on him
for that long
as he was already subdued and i thought
to me that was a hard sell
you know because he was already in
handcuffs he wasn't really moving around
i thought any reasonable cop i know
would have stood up
except i think it was the prosecution's
own witness who testified they did the
same thing
really that's why i'm like watching this
trial and i'm just confused as to how
this verdict came about
other than the jury walked in the room
as soon as the door closed
one guy goes i don't want anyone burning
my house down can we just say guilty we
all agree guilty okay
but we can't just come out right now and
say so how about we just order some
pizza
watch ratatouille yeah come back in the
morning and then say guilty
and make it seem like a done deal i
would think that maybe they could blur
obviously maybe not but blur the jurors
faces out and
modulate their voices and let us listen
to the deliberation
i just feel like at this time anybody
could be found out at this point yeah
and so i felt like and then the way
maxine waters was talking about it i
just felt like
they had no way out man if i was on a
jury like that
i just i just put my feet in like nah
and they'd be like we all want to go
home and no one wants their house burned
down i'll be like
okay i got time yeah not guilty
uh i'm sorry not guilty does not mean
he's innocent of any wrongdoing it means
there's reasonable doubt
you don't have to prove his innocence
you just have to doubt
the official story from the state the
state won it's it's amazing
the state are the are are they they
scapegoat chauvin
he's the problem but i want to mention
this one one quick thing back to that
earlier point
i'm pretty sure it was the prosecution's
witness that on cross-examination by the
defense
was asked have you ever subdued
somebody and held them down until ems
arrived and he said yes i have
it's like okay thank you so the jury can
hear that you also had the use of force
experts say
chauvin could have used a less uh uh he
could have used more force if he wanted
to he chose not to
and then nelson the defense was like so
chauvin chose to use
a lesser force option instead of just
immediately tasting i could have tased
him yeah yeah
basically he shoving could have jumped
out of a car walked right up and just
stuck the taser right into floyd
according to the
state's own witness so it's it's very
very obvious
there's no fair and impartial jury here
and i i'd be really surprised if
cowardly cahill actually decided to do
this
no the city doesn't care they're all
crooked they're all corrupt thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you